a las 10 de la mañana esta vivienda y
otras dos viviendas contiguas han
recibido el impacto de un misil ya han
quedado como pueden ver totalmente
destrozadas las tropas rusas están
bombardeando continuamente objetivos
civiles aquí en la ciudad de heart of y
los vecinos siguen estando todavía
conmocionados sin saber qué ha pasado
afortunadamente ninguno ha perdido la
vida porque a las diez de la mañana y
estas personas estaban fuera o bien
trabajando o uno de los vecinos estaba
paseando a su perro
mi casa todo está destruido pensé que
aquí vamos a estar seguros no sé qué voy
a hacer ahora porque nosotros justo
estaba en el jardín cuando empezaron las
explosiones hubo tres o cuatro
explosiones me tiré al suelo luego fui
corriendo hacia la casa aquí no hay
instalaciones militares
esta zona residencial era hasta hoy un
lugar seguro y es por eso que sus
vecinos sentían que estaban aquí a salvo
pero se ha demostrado que ningún lugar
deja es un sitio seguro